I think the cutting edge of medicine is
really not always hi-tech it's being
more focused on prevention and being
proactive understanding your genetics
for it $1,000 genome today we're will be
at $100 or even a free genome in the
next decade we know that sitting is the
new smoking
we now have wearables that we can stick
in our clothes and our cars and our
phones they're gonna help give us
insights into our behaviors we're in the
era of integrating exponential
technologies together I have in my
pocket a version of the first medical
tricorder a part of a clinical trial
from a company called scanner do that
started at singularity University so
it's a consumer you can track your vital
signs very readily that can help you do
a better job of understanding health
wellness early disease detection and
triage technologies like having an AI
doctor blended with sensors like this
one has in your pocket as a consumer
will help you be more proactive
realizing that the best drug is you know
walking doing 30 minutes of exercise a
day being reasonable about your diet and
when we can use some of these tools as
levers understanding that behavior
change is hard if you can look in the
mirror in the morning and see future you
and if your future you as a hundred
pounds heavier that might change your
your your lever on on behavior change we
can use
I think myers-briggs type things of
behavior change to understand your
carrot and your stick because just like
precision and personalized medicine not
anyone needs the same drug or the same
app or the same interface we can start
to use AI in feedback loops integrate it
into your workday and a graded into your
wearables into your apps to be more
proactive and if you think about how the
world ships it we've only had
smartphones for seven years the desktop
of 2000 fits on your smartphone and as
our now if it's on my Smart Watch which
can kind of give you a bit of a Google
nano not just leave work for early
because of traffic but you need to check
in the gym and get a few extra calories
today if you're gonna stay on track to a
certain goal or to help manage diabetes
or emphysema or heart disease and we're
seeing a whole new realm of digital
diagnostics in my pocket I have a
attachment as an otoscope than go in
your phone
I have 3d printed parts there's mini-me
you know so we have new tools that you
can use at home whether it's 3d printing
a cast if you've got a fracture and
here's an example from 3d systems scan
your fracture make one that fits you all
these things are enabling cheaper faster
more effective how
health care it could democratize it
around the planet you can have you know
telemedicine talking to your doctor or
nurse on skype anywhere in the planet
which has increasingly broadband
accessibility you're gonna have
Diagnostics labs on a chip it's not just
our quantified self data it's the
ability to do this on your smartphone or
to communicate that to a pathologist
here in New York from from rural Africa
all those things are shifting the power
curve to the empowered and engaged
consumer and patient who can be a data
donor can be connected to their own data
to gain insights early can have visits
with their clinician in more seamless
less expensive and less time-consuming
ways so weird interesting here in our
whether it's a tricorder or knowing your
own genomics or having embedded sensors
kind of like your own personal check
engine light can really shift healthcare
diagnostics and therapy in smart ways so
I think the most important thing anyone
can do is start owning their own health
using tools and apps to quit smoking get
on a diet tweet out their weight from
your scale all those things can come
together in powerful ways to be more
proactive and preventative as opposed to
waiting for disease to happen so be the
CEO of your own health don't wait for
your doctor to to tell you what you need
to do when you're in the ER or worse